This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. Many of us spend enormous amounts of time asking ourselves what other people think of us. Do they notice our flaws? Are they mocking us behind our backs? Do they think we're boring? This sort of rumination can be exhausting, anxiety-provoking, and above all else, it's often spectacularly wrong. There's just so many things that we mistakes that we fall into, these sort of social traps that lead us to be a lot more pessimistic
这里是“隐藏的大脑”，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔。我们许多人花费大量时间去问自己别人是怎么看我们的。他们会注意到我们的缺点吗？他们在背后嘲笑我们吗？他们觉得我们很无趣吗？这种反刍式的思考会让人筋疲力尽、焦虑不安，最重要的是，它往往错得离谱。我们总会陷入那么多误区、掉入这种社交陷阱，导致我们对自己的社交生活的悲观程度，
about our social lives than kind of reality warrants. Today on the show, why are assessments of how people see us can be so off-base and how these incorrect impressions shape our relationships at home and in the workplace. How to see the world with greater clarity and walk with greater confidence this week on Hidden Brain. When we talk to other people, we are often trying to figure them out. But we also try to guess what the other person thinks of us. We worry, how am I coming across? Am I flaws on prominent
远远超过了现实所合理支撑的程度。今天的节目将探讨：为什么我们对别人如何看待我们的评估会如此大相径庭，以及这些错误的印象如何塑造了我们在家庭和职场中的关系。本周的“隐藏的大脑”将教你如何以更清晰的视角看待世界，并带着更大的自信前行。当我们与他人交谈时，我们经常试图弄清楚他们是怎样的人。但我们也会试着去猜别人是怎么看我们的。我们会担心：我给人的印象怎么样？我的缺点是不是暴露得很明显？
display? Or does this person think I'm cool? Most of us think we are good judges of our social interactions that we can tell if other people like us. But new research suggests this is often not the case. Our perceptions of our social interactions are often distorted. At the University of Pennsylvania's Wharton School, psychologists Erica Boothby studies these distortions and what we can do about them. Erica Boothby, welcome to Hidden Brain. Thanks for having me. I'd like to take you back to the start of your interest in this topic, Erica. You were in grad school and sitting at a cafe with a friend
还是这个人觉得我很酷？我们大多数人都认为自己是社交互动的优秀裁判，能看出别人是否喜欢我们。但新的研究表明，事实往往并非如此。我们对社交互动的感知常常是扭曲的。在宾夕法尼亚大学沃顿商学院，心理学家埃里卡·布思比一直在研究这些扭曲现象以及我们能做些什么。埃里卡·布思比，欢迎来到“隐藏的大脑”。谢谢邀请我来。埃里卡，我想带你回到你对这个话题产生兴趣的最初。那时你在读研究生，和一个朋友坐在咖啡馆里，
and you'd also planned to meet a potential collaborator at the cafe. She showed up and you went over and started chatting. What happened next? Yeah, so I was at a cafe just down the street from my apartment called Cafe Romeo and I worked there a lot with my partner who's also a psychologist. And I went and left him, went to a couple tables down where I was talking to this person who I thought we might launch a collaboration. And I really got the sense from our conversation
而且你还计划在咖啡馆里见一位潜在的合作者。她出现了，你走过去开始聊天。接下来发生了什么？嗯，当时我在离我公寓不远的一家叫“罗密欧咖啡馆”的咖啡馆里，我和我的伴侣经常在那里工作，他也是个心理学家。然后我离开他，走到几张桌子外，和这个我认为可能会展开合作的人聊天。从我们的交谈中，我真的有一种感觉，
that she was a very interesting person and had a lot of interesting ideas. But as I was talking to my partner and debriefing him on how it had gone, I said, I really doubted that she would want to work with me. Because our conversation hadn't really gone all that well. I'd expected her to ask me about one stream of research. She instead took the conversation
觉得她是一个非常有趣的人，有很多有意思的想法。但当我回到伴侣身边并向他汇报情况时，我说，我真的怀疑她是否愿意和我合作。因为我们的谈话其实并没有那么顺利。我原本期望她会问我关于某个研究方向的问题。相反，她却把谈话引向了
in a totally different direction, and I was unprepared. And then my partner got a sheepish look on his face and he admitted that he'd actually been eavesdropping a little. But the good news was, is that he thought we had really hit it off and that I'd come off really well in the conversation. And so we had these wildly different perspectives on what had happened. So as psychologists, this guy was thinking,
完全不同的方向，而我毫无准备。然后我的伴侣脸上露出了羞涩的表情，他承认其实他刚才稍微偷听了一点。但好消息是，他觉得我们真的很合得来，而且我在谈话中表现得非常好。因此，对于刚才发生的事情，我们有着完全不同的看法。所以作为心理学家，这家伙当时在想，
who was right in this case, right? Who had a better read on the situation? Erika asked herself, whether the incident revealed something not just about her, but something about people in general. It was very curious that there was this kind of wide gap it seemed between what my partner had observed from the outside and what I had felt as someone
在这种情况下究竟谁是对的呢？谁对局势的把握更准确？埃里卡问自己，这件事是否不仅仅反映了她自己，而是反映了整个人类的普遍情况。令人感到好奇的是，我作为身处对话之中的当事人所感受到的，和我的伴侣作为局外人所观察到的，两者之间似乎存在着如此巨大的鸿沟。这让我们开始思考，这里面一定有一些有趣的心理学。为了验证这一点，埃里卡与来自英国的研究人员合作，他们正在组织个人发展工作坊，让许多陌生人在那里相聚。
on the inside of the conversation. And it got us thinking there must be some interesting psychology here. To test this, Erica teamed up with some researchers from the United Kingdom who were organizing personal development workshops where lots of strangers meet one another.
我们喜欢的是，这是在实验室之外进行的——我们最近正是在实验室里开展研究——这样我们就能看到这种现象在现实世界中是如何发生的。我们发现，人们认为自己的谈话对象比谈话对象认为他们自己要有趣得多。这当然就是你在咖啡馆里真切感受到的情况，也就是你觉得谈话进行得很顺利，但你认为你的潜在合作者可能不会觉得那么有趣。完全正确。
And what we like is that this was outside of the lab, which is where we recently run studies, and so we could see how this kind of happens in the real world. And we found that people believed their conversation partners were more interesting than they thought their conversation partners found them. Which is, of course, exactly what you had felt in the cafe, which is that you thought the conversation went well, but you believe that your potential collaborator would not have found it as interesting. Exactly.
在我身处“罗密欧咖啡馆”进行那次对话的情况下，我们并不确切知道另一个人（即潜在合作者）对我的看法。我们只知道我伴侣观察到的情况。所以有趣的是，随着我们继续深入研究，并将其实验范式化，
In the case of the work when I was in Cafe Romeo having this conversation, we didn't know exactly what the other person, the potential collaborator thought of me. We just knew what my partner had observed. And so what's interesting is that, as we continue to pursue this and bringing this into experimental
我们可以真正用现实来检验人们的感知。你用那些以为自己是在参加个人发展工作坊的志愿者所进行的实验，在某种程度上向你揭示了：你的经历并非个例，不仅仅是某一个人觉得享受了对话而另一个人没有，也不仅仅是某一个人觉得享受了对话而另一个人没有，而是双方都享受了对话，但双方都以为对方没有那么投入对话。你想出了一个词来描述这种现象。
paradigms, we could really test people's perceptions against reality. The experiment that you conducted with the volunteers who thought they were part of a personal development workshop, it revealed to you in some ways that the experience that you had was not unique, and it wasn't just that one person thinks that they enjoyed the conversation by the other person did not, but thinks that they enjoyed the conversation by the other person did not, but that both people enjoyed the conversation, but both believed that the other would be less into the conversation. You came up with a term for this phenomenon.
埃里卡，那个词是什么？这就是“喜欢间隙”（The Liking Gap）。“喜欢间隙”就是这种现象。它通常发生在初次相识的人之间。所以当你结识新欢时，你会进行那次初步的交谈。事后，你会回想谈话的进展。最常见的是，人们其实很享受这些初次的谈话，并且相当喜欢对方。
What was that term, Erica? This is the Liking Gap. And the Liking Gap is the phenomenon. It was commonly this happens among people who are getting acquainted for the first time. And so when you're meeting someone new, you're having that initial conversation. Afterward, you reflect on how it went. And most often, people actually enjoy these initial conversations and like the other person quite a bit.
但他们往往低估了对方有多喜欢他们、有多享受他们的谈话。你对刚开始作为潜在宿舍室友互相了解的大一新生做了一个类似的实验。那个实验中发生了什么？作为潜在宿舍室友，那个实验中发生了什么？没错，在这个案例中，我们其实很好奇，随着时间的推移，当人们越来越了解彼此后，我们是否还会看到喜欢间隙。因此，我们在9月份刚到学校报到时招募了大学室友，他们被随机塞进一个房间里，室友是他们从未见过的人，
But they tend to underestimate how much the other person likes them and enjoy their conversation. You ran a similar experiment with first-year college students who are getting to know one another as potential dorm mates. What happened in that experiment? as potential dorm mates, what happened in that experiment? Right, so in that case, we were actually curious to see whether we would see a laking gap as people increasingly get to know each other over time. And so we recruited college roommates who had just landed at school for the first time in September, and they get thrown into a room with someone they've never met
对于他们来说，一个巨大的问题就是对方会不会喜欢自己。这真的对他们很重要。因此，我们在9月到5月之间的五个不同时间点追踪了这些新室友。我们询问他们有多喜欢自己的室友，以及他们觉得自己有多受室友喜欢。我们在那里发现的是，在好几个月的时间里，人们其实都低估了室友有多喜欢他们，
before, and a huge question for them is whether the other person is going to like them. And that really matters to them. And so we tracked these new roommates at five different time points between September and May. We asked them how much they liked their roommates and how much they thought their roommates liked them. And what we found there was that people actually underestimated how much their roommate like them for several
比如通过秋季一直到春季，最后到了年底，我们确实发现喜欢间隙消失了。但你也以此为基础进一步提出，这可能并不是我们误判别人对我们的看法以及互动进展的唯一领域。埃里卡，谈谈你是如何以及何时决定这不仅仅关乎一件事，不仅仅关乎喜欢间隙，而是关乎一组更广泛的现象，你最终将其描述为社交错觉的？
months, like through the fall, into the spring, and finally by the end of the year, we did see that the liking gap went away. But you also took this idea and built on it to suggest that it might be that this is not the only place in which we misjudge how other people think of us and how the interaction is going. Talk about how and when you decided that this was not just about one thing, Erica, just about the lacking gap, but about a much larger set of phenomena that you eventually came to describe as social illusions.
是的，所以我们一直在试图弄清楚别人对我们的看法。我算是把这个谜题拆解了，并聚焦于它的好几个不同方面。我觉得我们确实容易陷入这么多的事情、这么多的误区，掉入这种社交错觉的陷阱，导致我们对自己的社交生活的悲观程度，
Yeah, so we're constantly trying to figure out what other people think of us. And I have sort of taken this puzzle and zoomed in on several different facets of it. And I think there's just so many things that we, mistakes that we fall into, these sort of social traps that lead us to be a lot more pessimistic about our social lives
远远超出了现实所合理支撑的程度。嗯。我想在节目后半部分讨论一些方法，帮助我们克服对人际关系认知的这些扭曲。但我想先看看这些扭曲有多普遍。我想到电影《当哈利遇到莎莉》。里面有一个经典场景，哈利和莎莉
than kind of reality warrants. Mm. I want to talk later in the episode about ways we can get past some of these distortions in our perceptions of our social relationships. But I want to look at how common these distortions are. I'm thinking about the movie when Harry met Sally. There's this classic scene when Harry and Sally
终于走到了一起，然后分别跟各自的朋友聊起进展如何。我很担心。我不得不离开那里。他突然就消失了。聊聊进展如何。我太尴尬了。我不怪他。这太糟糕了。我想我感冒了。不，要是行得通的话本来会很好的，但没行得通。我晚点打给你，好吗？好的，拜拜。
finally get together and then have separate conversations with friends about how it went. I'm worried. I had to get out of there. He just disappeared. about how it went. I'm so embarrassed. I don't blame him. That's horrible. I think I'm catching a cold. No, it would have been great if it worked out, but it didn't. I'll call you later, okay? Okay, bye.
拜拜。拜拜。所以，你知道的，在我读了你的作品之后再听到那个片段，埃里卡，我感到震惊的是，我们为了试图理解这些社交互动投入了多少时间和精力，而我们又经常把事情搞错。我太喜欢这个了。这是一个极好的例子，说明了我们如何不把内心的想法和感受告诉对方。相反，我们往往把它们向其他人表达，对吧？这有助于让这些错觉长盛不衰。是的。有没有可能，其中某些社交错觉在诸如约会这样高压、高风险的情况下，实际上被放大了呢？我的意思是，这些浪漫的场景，
Bye. Bye. So, you know, when I hear that clip after reading your work, Erica, I'm struck by how much time and effort we put into trying to understand these social interactions and how often we get things wrong. I love that. It's a great example of how we don't tell each other the things that we're thinking and that we feel. We express them instead oftentimes to other people, right? And this helps keep these illusions alive. Yeah. Is it possible that some of these social illusions, in fact, are amplified during, you know, high pressure, high-stake situations like dating? I mean, can these romantic situations, for
比如，会不会给“喜欢间隙”火上浇油？是的，我的意思是，我认为只要我们在乎别人对我们的看法，我们就会给自己施加额外的压力，要求自己以最高水平表现。所以在那些时刻，我们会对那些未能达到自己理想行为、说错话或没说该说的话的方面保持高度敏感。因此，如果我们极度在乎自己给人的印象，这些方面对我们来说就会格外突显。所以我们已经探讨了社交错觉的一个重要维度。让我们来看另一个。同样，让我们回到你的研究生时光。
example, put the liking gap on steroids? Yeah, I mean, I think anytime where we really, really care about what someone else thinks of us, we're going to put extra pressure on ourselves to perform at the highest level. And so in those moments, we're going to be hyper aware of the ways that we're falling short of the way that we wish we behaved or the things we wish we said or hadn't said. And so those are going to be extra salient to us to the extent that we care a lot about how we're coming off. So we've looked at one important dimension of social illusions. Let's look at another. And again, let's go back to your time in graduate school.
有一段时间，你对表现得足够聪明、足够优秀以留在研究生院感到非常自我意识过剩。有一次，你在酒吧和几个朋友聊天，谈话转向了大家正在看的电视节目。对的。大家当时基本上都处于互相了解的最早阶段。直到今天，我依然不知道为什么我会那样回答，但不管出于什么原因，我说我看了《单身汉》。把女人们带上来！
At one point, you were really self-conscious about appearing smart enough and good enough to being grad school. And one time, you were talking with some friends at a bar, and the conversation turned to the TV shows that people were watching. Right. Everyone was still kind of in the earliest ages getting to know one another. And to this day, I still don't know why this was my response, but for whatever reason, I said I watched the Bachelor. Bring on the women!
等等，这就像是全套大礼包。正如谈话常有的那样，那之后不久话题就自然而然地转到了别处。但那天晚些时候，我脑子里一直不断地回放那个时刻，反复琢磨着。因为我实在不敢相信，当我跟一群我非常想留下深刻印象的人在一起时，我竟然会脱口而出这个节目。你知道我们听到的，大男孩。我觉得类似的事情一直在我们身上发生，你知道的，琐碎的
Wait, this is like the whole package. As conversations do, it kind of just drifted to another topic pretty quickly after that. But later that night, I kept kind of coming back to that moment and just replaying it in my head. Because I just couldn't believe that that was the show that I came up with when I was with a bunch of people that I really wanted to impress. You know we hear it, big boy. And I feel like something like this happens to us all the time, that you know, trivial
事情发生了，我们说了或做了某些事情，然后我们在接下来的几个小时甚至几周里对此念念不忘、反复咀嚼，你知道的，猜测别人是怎么看我们的，内心备受煎熬。完全正确。我们的想法基本上就是彻底失控了。比如：要是我没那样说呢？要是我刚才说的是我看的那档国家地理节目呢？像，我为什么会那样做？要是我刚才说的是我看的那档国家地理节目呢？像，我为什么会那样说？
things happen, we say or do things, and then we perseverate on this for hours or sometimes for weeks afterwards, you know, wondering what people thought of us and eating ourselves up on the inside. Exactly. Our thoughts basically just run wild. Like, what if I hand on it? What if I had talked about the National Geographic show I watched instead? Like, why did I had done it? What if I had talked about the National Geographic show I watched instead? Like, why did I say that?
本来应该聊聊你非常崇拜的肯·伯恩斯的纪录片。完全正确。我总是想，你知道的，比如，天哪，他们肯定在因为那个而评判我，对吧？我说错了话。那在这种情况下发生了什么？你有没有发现你研究生院的朋友们是否因为你看《单身汉》而对你有所看低？所以，是的，几天后，我居然遇到了当时在场的一个人。她问我愿不愿意加入她，和每周一起看《单身汉》的朋友们一起看。
Should have talked about the Ken Burns documentaries that you're a big fan of. Exactly. I always think, you know, like, oh god, they're just judging me for that, right? I said the wrong thing. And what happened in this case? Did you ever discover whether your friends and graduate school thought less of you because you watched the Bachelor? So, yeah, a few days later, I actually ran into someone who was at that conversation. And she asked me if I wanted to join her as my friends who watched the Bachelor together every week.
哈哈哈哈。哈哈哈哈。单身汉又回来了。哈哈哈哈。所以很显然，我并没有自己想象的那么孤单。哈哈哈哈。我们已经讨论了一些你所研究的社交错觉是如何在与陌生人、熟人甚至开始互相了解的人的互动中产生的。
Ha ha ha. Ha ha ha. The Bachelor's back. Ha ha ha ha. So clearly I wasn't as alone as I thought. Ha ha ha. We've talked a bit about how some of the social illusions that you study arise in interactions with people who are strangers or acquaintances or even people who are starting to get to know one another.
但社交错觉同样会影响长期存在的关系。因此我想播放一段来自《贝莱尔的新鲜王子》的片段，威·史密斯扮演的角色担心他的叔叔——过去几年一直照顾他的叔叔——会看不起他。我只是不希望你觉得我还是刚搬到这里时那个愚蠢的小屁孩。你怎么可能会这么想呢？
But social illusions can also affect long-standing relationships. So I want to play a clip from the fresh prince of Belair, our Will Smith's character is Wari that is uncle, who has been taking care of him for the past several years, thinks poorly of him. I just don't want you to think that I'm this same stupid kid I was when I first moved out here. How could you possibly believe it?
我才会这么想。看看你。你要独立搬出去了。你一年后就要大学毕业了。你要独立搬出去了。你一年后就要大学毕业了。你正在成为一个男人。一个让我无比骄傲的男人。我只是不希望你对我的最后记忆比最初的好不到哪里去。你根本不知道我对你的最初记忆是什么。
That's what I'd be thinking. Look at you. You're moving out on your own. You're going to finish college in a year. You're moving out on your own. You're gonna finish college in a year. You're becoming a man. Man, I'm damn proud of. I just don't want your last memory of me to be no better than the first one. You have no idea what my first memory of you is.
我记得一个浑身充满无限潜能的小孩。你根本不知道我对你的最初记忆是什么。我记得一个浑身充满无限潜能的小孩。现在我看到的是一个即将兑现自己潜能的人。埃里卡，你能谈谈这个吗？对某人的熟悉并不自动意味着这些社交错觉就会消失。没错，我认为对于我们不了解的人来说，这些错觉会更加极端，很大程度上只是因为我们不知道他们的想法，
I remember a kid loaded with all the potential in the world. You have no idea what my first memory of you is. I remember a kid loaded with all the potential in the world. And now I see a person on the verge of realizing their potential. Can you talk about this a moment, Erika? A familiarity with someone doesn't automatically mean that these social illusions disappear. Right, I think they are more extreme for people we do not know, in large part, just because we don't know how they think
也不知道他们会因为什么样的事情去评判别人。但即使我们和别人的关系变得更加亲密，这也并非板上钉钉的保证，因为我们无法接触到那些人内心的每一个想法。所以我们确实会产生差距，即使你和某人的关系变得更亲密时依然如此。因此，其中一些社交错觉的后果并不总是很严重。
or what kinds of things they judge people for. But even as we get closer to people, it's not a guarantee, because we don't have access to every single thing that those people think. And so we do, there is kind of a gap. There's still even as you get closer to someone. So the consequences of some of these social illusions are not always serious.
有时它们会很滑稽。亚当·马斯特里亚尼和他的同事最近发表了一项研究，探讨人们希望谈话何时结束。他们发现，当A方希望谈话结束时，谈话几乎从不结束。当A方希望谈话结束时，他们发现，谈话几乎从不结束，而当B方希望谈话结束时，谈话也不会结束；有时谈话结束的时间比任何一方希望的都要短，有时则比任何一方希望的要长得多。我觉得这说明了
Sometimes they can be funny. Adam Mastriani and his colleagues recently published a study looking at when people want conversations to end. And they found that conversations almost never end when person A want conversations to end. And they found that conversations almost never end when person A wants them to end, and they don't then when person B wants them to end either, conversations sometimes run shorter than either party wants, and sometimes they run much longer than either party wants. And I feel like the speak to the gap
我们认为谈话进展如何与我们认为对方对谈话有何看法之间的差距。是的，完全正确。我非常喜欢这项研究。我认为，这同样是因为我们对于自己的需求没有对彼此明说。我们依赖于许多暗示性的线索，
between how we think a conversation is going, and what we think the other person thinks about the conversation. Yeah, exactly. I love that work. And I think it's, again, because we aren't explicit with each other about what we want. We rely on a lot of implicit cues,
而这正是许多社交生活和谈话运作的方式。因此我认为，我们往往只是寄希望于自己能够理解对方的需求、了解他们何时想结束谈话，然后我们再温和地让他们离开。没错。但我们经常搞错。
and that's how a lot of social life and a lot of conversation operates. So I think that we tend to just sort of hope that we're able to understand what the other person wants and when they might want to get out of the conversation then we gently let them go. Right. But we often get that wrong.
是的。在那篇论文中，研究人员写道，人类常常无法解决这些问题，因为解决这些问题需要人们分享他们通常对彼此隐瞒的信息。所以问题不仅在于我们没有感知到事物，还在于我们正在积极地隐瞒那些能让对方得出正确结论的信息。
Yeah. In that paper, the researchers write that humans are often unable to solve these problems because solving these problems requires people to share information that they normally keep from each other. So the problem is not just that we're not perceiving things, but we're actively hiding the information that would allow the other person in fact to draw the right conclusions.
没错，这就是个问题。我的意思是，深入思考这些事情确实让我意识到，如果我们能对某些事情更加明确一点，会有所帮助。我知道我们并不总是想亮出全部底牌。但也许，比如我研究过的那些大学室友，如果他们能早一点亮出底牌，你知道的，早几个月，也许情况就会更清晰一些。但我认为我们在很多方面都非常有戒备心。在面对被拒绝或可能被拒绝时，我们非常厌恶风险。而这真正向我们展示的是注意力的力量，以及我们专注于什么。
Right, that's a problem. I mean, I think thinking about these things a lot does make me aware that it would help if we could be more explicit about some things. I know that we don't always want to play our hand fully. But maybe if these college roommates that I studied for example had played their hands just a little sooner, you know, a few months before, maybe things would have been a little bit clearer to people. But I think we're very guarded in a lot of ways. We're very risk-averse when it comes to getting rejected or the possibility of rejection. And what it really shows us is the power of our attention and what we're focused on.
如果我们专注于我们投射到别人身上的关于自己的负面想法，那会占据巨大的分量，并且往往会掩盖其他可能同样真实的事情。多年来，社会学家一直在警告全球性的孤独流行。社交隔离会导致抑郁、焦虑和药物滥用。慢性孤独会增加患心脏病和其他疾病的风险。其中一个解决方案是意识到我们许多人的朋友其实比我们意识到的要多？节目回来后，我们将探讨那些让我们难以清晰看待社交互动的心理机制，以及我们如何能够做得更好。
And if we are focused on the negative thoughts about ourselves that we're projecting onto other people, that looms really large and it tends to obscure other things that might actually also be true. For years, social scientists have been warning about a global epidemic of loneliness. Social isolation contributes to depression, anxiety, and drug abuse. Chronic loneliness increases the risk of heart disease and other illnesses. Is one solution to see that many of us actually have more friends than we realize? When we come back, the mechanisms in the mind that make it difficult for us to see our social interactions clearly and how we can do better.
你正在收听的是“隐藏的大脑”，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔。我们许多人度过了一个又一个的不眠之夜，担心别人怎么看我们，但我们在别人眼中看到的自己往往是扭曲的。我们误读了互动，过度思考自己的不安全感。我们没有注意到别人实际上是怎么看我们的。埃里卡·布思比和她的同事研究了这些社交错觉背后的心理机制。埃里卡，你曾作为高中交换生在意大利生活过。你会说意大利语吗？我其实不会说意大利语。
You're listening to Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. Many of us spend sleepless nights worrying about what others think of us, but the reflections we see of ourselves in the eyes of others are often distorted. We misread interactions, overthink our own insecurities. We fail to notice what other people actually notice about us. Erica Boothby and her colleague studied the psychological mechanisms behind these social illusions. Erica, you lived in Italy as a high school exchange student. Did you speak Italian? So I didn't speak Italian.
我只上过一个针对意大利语的快速强化班，基本上是为了旅行准备的。所以我学到了一些诸如从1数到10之类的。我还会说我叫埃里卡。我是美国人。也许还有其他一些东西。差不多也就是这种程度了。而且那是全浸泡式的。
I had taken just a quick kind of crash course in Italian, which was for traveling essentially. So I learned things like how to count to 10. And I could say my name is Erica. I'm American. Maybe a couple other things. That was kind of the extent of it. And it was full immersion.
所以我跟一个意大利家庭住在一起，上的是意大利的高中。我感觉挺尴尬的，因为我没法真正跟别人进行对话。因此，哪怕是在家里和寄宿家庭围坐在餐桌旁时，我很想聊聊我的一天。我很想能够告诉他们，但我们就是做不到。这真的非常具有挑战性。在学校和同学相处时，我也发现了同样的情况。
So I was living with an Italian family, and I was going to Italian high school. And I felt pretty awkward because I couldn't really engage in conversations with people. So even at home with the host family sitting around the dinner table, I would want to know about my day. I'd want to be able to tell them, but we just couldn't get there. And it was really challenging. And I found the same thing at school with my classmates.
大家在课间都会站在一起聊天。而我就会尴尬地站在那里，琢磨着自己怎么才能插进对话或者说点什么。但那时我的语言水平实在是太匮乏了。要参与社交生活真的很难。不过，随着我逐渐了解别人，我的语言能力也有所提高，
They'd all stand around and chat during the breaks. And I would kind of stand there awkwardly, trying to figure out how I could jump into the conversation or say something. But my talent was just so impoverished at the time. It was really hard to partake in social life. But as I kind of got to know people and my language skills improved,
在我呆那儿的一年时间里，我的语言能力提高了很多。我开始意识到，别人对我的批判性想法并没有我想象的那么多。我之前一直在进行大量的自我投射，并且对自己感到非常沮丧，但那些根本就不是他们脑子里在想的事情。
they improved a lot over the course of the year that I was there. I started to realize that people didn't have as many critical thoughts about me as I had about myself. I'd been projecting a lot of that and getting really down on myself, but those weren't really the thoughts they were having at all.
是的，所以作为身处这种情境中的高中生，你为什么会专注于自己的不安全感，或者在你努力学习和说意大利语时犯下的错误，这完全是可以理解的。但当然，你周围的人心里大概在想，瞧，这是一个来自美国的聪明年轻女孩，花时间和精力来学习我们的语言，你知道的，他们心里可能对你充满了敬意，尽管你可能内心充满了不安全感。是的，我希望当时能意识到这一点。相反，是的，我非常没有安全感，
Yeah, so it's totally understandable as a high school student in a situation like this, why you would be focused on your insecurities or the mistakes that you're making as you are trying to learn and speak Italian. But of course, the people who are around you are probably thinking, you know, here's this, you know, bright young girl from the United States who's taking the time and trouble to learn our language, you know, and they're probably filled with admiration for you even as you might be filled with insecurity. Yeah, I wish I'd realized that at the time. But instead, yeah, I was very insecure
而且我因为没法真正融入这些对话而感到尴尬。但我确实也认为，这种经历不仅仅适用于身处外国的人，因为总的来说，我们的谈话对象都是相当宽容的。人们并不真的介意你搞砸了或者没有把一切都完美表达出来。这其实就是谈话运作的方式，而且大家对此也有所预期。你目前在沃顿商学院教授一门谈判课程，你连续上两个90分钟的小节。所以你
and I felt awkward that I couldn't really engage in these conversations. But I do think also that this experience doesn't just apply to people in a foreign country because in general, our conversation partners are pretty charitable. People don't really care if you mess up or if you don't say everything perfectly. That's kind of just how conversation works and people expect it. You currently teach a negotiations course at Wharton and you have two 90-minute sections back to back. So you're
在极短的间隔内把同一场讲座讲了两遍。埃里卡，当你这么做时，你脑子里闪过的社交错觉是什么？在社交互动中往往会发生的一件事是，我们常常觉得自己的内部状态、我们的情绪、我们的想法，仿佛都摆在展台上供所有人观看。并且我们认为人们在形成对我们的评价时正在使用这些信息。这通常被称为“透明度错觉”。所以，是的，我教这门课，连续上两个小节。
giving the same lecture twice with very little time in between. What is the social illusion that goes through your head as you do this, Erica? One thing that tends to happen in social interactions is that we often feel like our internal states, our emotions, our thoughts, our kind of on display for everyone to see. And we think that people are using that information when they're forming their evaluations of us. And this is something that is often called the illusion of transparency. And so yeah, I teach this course, two sections back to back.
在第一节课上，我充满了活力。但到了第二场讲座时，我知道自己开始有点精力耗尽了。所以我觉得我的第二节课永远没有第一节课好，因为我在拿它跟第一节课作比较，而那时我更有活力。因此，在学期结束时，每当我看到两节课的评分相同时，我总是感到惊讶。这恰恰说明了，当我在内部试图想象别人如何评价我时，
And in the first section, I am full of energy. But by the second lecture, I know that I'm starting to get a little depleted. And so I feel like my second class is never as good as the first class, because I'm comparing it to the first class, and I had more energy then. And so at the end of the semester, I'm always surprised when I looked at my ratings for the two classes, and they are identical. And so this just goes to show from the inside when I'm trying to imagine how other people are evaluating me.
我正在使用所有他们并没有使用的比较标准，对吧？我累了。我第二次讲得没那么机智，但当然我的第二节课并不等于我的第一节课。因此对他们来说，我的讲座看起来完全没问题。所以我想我们在谈话中也做了完全相同的事情。因此，当我们给别人讲故事，或者向别人总结我们在公司正在进行的一个项目时，我们清楚地知道所有的那些小瑕疵，以及我们所说的各种细节，或者我们上次描述时表达得更好的地方，但我们的谈话对象并没有像我们那样多的比较基准。
I'm using all these comparisons that they're not using, right? I'm tired. I wasn't as witty the second time, but of course my second class wasn't at my first class. And so to them, my lecture seems perfectly fine. And so I think we do the same exact thing in conversation. So when we tell people a story, or we give people a summary of a project we're working on at work, we know all the little flaws and the things we say, or the things that we said better last time we describe them, but our conversation partners don't have as much to compare to as we do.
所以他们看到的完全不一样。埃里卡曾做过实验，确切揭示了人们对彼此注意到了多少。在一项研究中，她让志愿者穿上一件衬衣去见另一个人。其中的玄机呢？这件衬衣的前面印着巴勃罗·埃斯科巴的照片，他是臭名昭著的哥伦比亚大毒枭，犯下了数十起谋杀案。我们把人请进来，把实验室当作候车室来对待，基本上改造了它，我们每次让两名参与者进来，他们在这张大桌子两端面对面坐着，其中一个人穿着这件巴勃罗·埃斯科巴衬衣，而另一个人
And so they're seeing it totally differently. Erica has conducted experiments that reveal exactly how much people notice about one another. In one study, she had volunteers put on a shirt and go to meet another person. The catch? The shirt had a photo in the front of Pablo Escobar, the infamous Colombian drug lord responsible for dozens of murders. We brought people in, we treated the lab like a waiting room, we basically converted it, and we had two participants come in at a time, they sat across from one another at this large table, and one person had on this Pablo Escobar shirt, and the other person was just
在他们不知情的情况下，被指定为我们的观察员。然后事后我们测量了那个观察员注意并思考另一个人、对方的外表以及关于对方的一切的程度。我们询问穿巴勃罗·埃斯科巴衬衣的那个人，他们觉得另一个人对他们的关注度有多少。我猜想他们中的大多数人会相信另一个人敏锐地察觉到他们穿着印有毒枭照片的衬衣。实际情况确实如此吗？没有，穿衬衣的人感到非常自我意识过剩，但从另一个人的角度来看，那不过是对方刚好随便穿的一件衣服而已。
without them knowing it, they were assigned to be our observer. And then afterward we measured how much that observer had been noticing and thinking about the other person, what they looked like, anything about them. And we asked the person wearing the Pablo Escobar shirt, how much attention they thought the other person was paying to them. I'm imagining that most of them would believe that the other person is keenly aware that they're wearing a photo of a drug kingpin. Was that in fact what happened? No, the person wearing the shirt is very self-conscious, but from the other person's perspective, that was just whatever they happened to be wearing.
因此，穿着巴勃罗·埃斯科巴衬衣的人高估了别人对他们衬衣的注意力，因为那是他们自己高度聚焦的东西。但其他人关注的是关于这个人的各种其他事情。你知道的，比如他们在做什么，他们有没有看手机，他们看起来是不是刚从健身房出来，我不知道是什么想法，但他们并没有特别关注那件衬衣。因此，当我们思考与其他人之间的互动时，埃里卡，我们往往专注于关于我们自己的极其微小的细节，你知道的，我们的发型如何，或者我们穿着的衣服
And so people who were wearing the public Eskivar shirt overestimated how much tension was on their shirt because that was the thing that they were hyper focused on. But people were paying attention to all kinds of other things about the person. You know, like what they were doing, did they go on their phone, did they look like they just came from the gym, like I don't know whatever the thoughts were, but they were not paying attention to the shirt specifically. So when we think about the interactions that we have with other people, Erica, we're often focused on the very minute things about ourselves, you know, how our hair looks or the clothes
或者我们衬衣上的照片，而事实上，其他人并没有在微观层面上打量我们。你能聊聊我们所研究的那些因为人们并没有以我们评价自己的那种颗粒度来评价我们而产生的错觉吗？每当我们注意到某些事情并为此感到担忧时，正如你所说，你知道的，我剪了个新发型。现在这就是我关注的焦点，我的头发感觉太短了。别人肯定一眼就能看出，但你知道的，实际上，别人并没有注意到关于我们的那个特定事情，对吧？也就是我们碰巧关注或感到自我意识过剩的事情。
we are wearing or the picture on our shirt and other people in fact are not taking us in at this micro level. Can you talk about some of the illusions that we use study coming about because people are not evaluating us with the granularity with which we're evaluating ourselves. Whenever we're paying attention to something and we're concerned about it, like you said, you know, I got a new haircut. Now that's when I'm paying attention to my hair feels so short. I must be obvious to other people, but you know, in reality, people aren't noticing that specific thing about us, right? The thing that we happen to be focused on or self-conscious about.
但这并不意味着人们没有以其他方式关注我们，或者对我们产生其他想法。我怀疑我们在评价别人时也是如此。当我们评价一个初次见面的人时，我们真正试图对他们是谁有一个整体印象。我能和这个人相处融洽吗？我们并没有带着很高的颗粒度去审视他们。完全正确。我认为这确实触及了一个非常深刻的真相。所以我们只是试图弄清楚，是敌是友，对吧？
But that doesn't mean that people aren't paying attention to us in other ways or having other thoughts about us. I suspect this is true of us in terms of our evaluations of others. When we're evaluating someone we meet for the first time, we are really trying to get a global impression of who they are. Will I be able to get along with this person? We're not looking at them with great granularity. Exactly. I think that really captures a really deep truth. And so we're trying to just figure out, friend or foo, right?
我们处于一个宏观层面。我们像是在想：他们会伤害我们吗？还是他们会成为我们的朋友？他们看起来像是个足够好的人吗？也许我能信任他们吗？然而，当我们担心被评判，或者当我们处于另一端时，我们在微观层面上思考的是我们是否说错了话，而这实际上并不是我们被评判的标准。没错。你知道的，我记起几年前发生过这样一件事，BBC正在对韩国政治进行现场直播，
We're at a high level. We're like, are they going to hurt us? Or are they going to be our friends? Do they seem like a nice enough person? Maybe can I trust them? Whereas when we're worried about being judged or when we're on the other side, we're thinking at the micro level in terms of did we say something wrong, and that's really not what we're being judged on. Right. You know, I'm reminded of this incident a few years ago, the BBC was doing a live
采访一位美国教授。埃里卡，你不知道你看没看过这个，但这位教授看起来非常严肃，并解释了为什么弹劾韩国总统是一件好事。我其实为韩国人感到相当骄傲，我并不是想听起来居高临下，但我已经在那里生活了10年了。这可能是我在那里生活过最好的一天了。
interview about South Korean politics with an American professor. I don't know if you've seen this, Erica, but the professor was looking very serious and explaining why the impeachment of the South Korean president was a good thing. I'm actually quite proud of the Koreans, I don't mean to sound kind of sending, but I've been living here for 10 years. This is probably the best day I've actually lived here.
我的意思是，我实际上对他们如何做到这一点印象相当深刻。然后他正说着话，他梳着两个小辫的小女儿蹦蹦跳跳地走进他的办公室，教授试图保持镇定并将她推开。呃，我会很惊讶他们会这么做。呃，请原谅我。然后一个婴儿用那种婴儿学步车滑了进来，后面跟着一个四肢着地爬行的女人，
I mean, I'm actually quite impressed at how they've done this. And then he was, as he was talking, his young daughter with pigtails bounces into his office and the professor tries to maintain his composure and push her away. Um, I would be surprised that they do. The um, pardon me. And then a baby paddles in on one of those baby walkers followed by a woman who's crawling on all fours,
试图把两个孩子都拖出房间，而教授则继续着他的分析。现在他的孩子们在背景里号啕大哭。我觉得我们所有人都曾以这样或那样的形式经历过疫情期间的这种状况，我们的真实生活在某种程度上侵入了我们试图在别人面前建立的印象。但在某种程度上，这暴露了我们为了呈现某种自我印象而付出的努力。在某些方面，我们害怕如果别人能简单地看清真实的我们会发生什么。是的，这是一个极好的例子。我认为这太真实了。我们所有人都非常关心印象
trying to drag both kids out of the room and the professor keeps going on with his analysis. Now his kids are wailing in the background. And I feel like all of us have been there in one form or another during the pandemic, where our real lives in some ways have intruded on the impression that we're trying to create on others. But I feel it reveals the lengths we go to present a certain impression of ourselves. And in some ways, our fears of what would happen if other people could simply see us as we are. Yeah, that's a great example. I think it's so true. We're all very concerned about impression
管理。我们希望人们以某种特定的光环来看待我们。从某种意义上说，这其实没那么重要，因为我认为人们对我们的宽容度远超我们的预期。他们会把那些事情解释过去。它们让我们显得更有亲和力。因此我认为我们会担心，因为我们对如何在其他人面前留下印象有着某种愿景。但在现实中，我们大概完全可以表现得更自然、更本色一点。
management. We want people to see us in a certain light. And in some ways, it doesn't matter all that much, because I think people are much more charitable toward us than we expect. They kind of explain away those things. They make us relatable. And so I think we can be worried because we have some vision of how we want to come off to other people. But in reality, we could probably stand to be a little bit more just ourselves.
所以我们已经探讨了不同的方式。人们高估了别人会如何评判他们以及如何严厉地评判他们。我想给你播放一段关于一个略有不同想法的电影片段。这是来自《哈利·波特与魔法石》。哈利和他的挚友罗恩在霍格沃茨学校拆圣诞礼物，哈利发现他收到了一件神秘的礼物。这是什么？某种斗篷。好吧，让我们看看，把它穿上。
So we've looked at different ways. People overestimate how others will judge them and judge them harshly. I want to play you a movie clip about it's slightly different idea. This is from Harry Potter and the Sorcerer's Stone. Harry and his best friend Ron are opening Christmas presents at Hogwarts School and Harry finds he has received a mysterious gift. Why is it? It's some kind of cloak. Well, let's see them, put it on.
哇！我的身体消失了！我知道那是什么。那是隐形斗篷。我隐形了。所以埃里卡，原来不光是巫师才拥有隐形斗篷！我隐形了。所以埃里卡，原来不光是巫师才拥有隐形斗篷。你曾经做过一项研究，在自助餐厅调查人们，询问他们
Woah! My body's gone! I know what that is. That's an invisibility cloak. I'm invisible. So turns out Erica, it's not just wizards who own invisibility coke! I'm invisible. So turns out Erica, it's not just wizards who own invisibility cloaks. You once ran a study where you surveyed people in a cafeteria and asked them how much they
观察别人的程度以及他们觉得自己被别人观察的程度。你发现了什么？我们发现，人们认为自己观察别人的程度，远超他们自己被观察的程度。所以这几乎就像人们觉得自己是隐形的，但他们可以看穿别人穿的隐形斗篷。完全正确。埃里卡提到了现实生活中的一个例子。2017年，唐纳德·特朗普总统的两名律师正在华盛顿特区市中心的一家餐厅吃午饭。
were watching other people and how much they thought other people were watching them. What did you find? We found that people thought that they were observing others far more than they themselves were being observed. So it's almost like people felt like they were invisible, but they could pierce the invisibility cloaks that other people were wearing. Exactly. Erica mentions a real life example of this. In 2017, two of President Donald Trump's lawyers were having lunch at a restaurant in downtown Washington DC.
他们当时在讨论国家机密大事。这就是泰·科布和约翰·道德在华盛顿特区市中心这个繁忙的户外露台共进午餐的时候。所以提醒大家一下，科布是负责协调白宫对穆勒调查回应的律师，他们当时在调查特朗普与俄罗斯涉嫌的纠葛。而道德是特朗普在此次调查中的首席外部律师，他们俩在这个午餐会上讨论了非常敏感的信息。所以他们讨论了正在进行的调查，以及关于贾里德·库什纳的一些事情。这些都是他们认为自己当时是在
They were discussing serious matters of state. This is when Thai Cobb and John Dowd met for lunch at this busy, outdoor patio in downtown Washington DC. So Cobb, just to remind everyone, was the lawyer in charge of coordinating the White House's responses to the Mueller investigation and they were looking at a Trump's alleged entanglements with Russia. And dad was Trump's lead outside attorney in the investigation and the two of them were discussing very sensitive information at this lunch. So they talked about the ongoing investigation, some things about Jared Kushner. And these were all things they thought that they were discussing
私下里他们之间讨论的事情。当然，刚好有一名《纽约时报》的记者坐在隔壁桌，就那位记者而言，这两个人周围可没有什么隐形斗篷。没错。他们绝对没有。所以这位记者实际上在推特上发布了一张这两位律师交谈的照片，配文是：“这是泰·科布和约翰·道德在华盛顿特区BLT Steak餐厅随意且大声地讨论俄罗斯调查细节的照片。”嗯，我坐在隔壁桌。
privately just amongst themselves. And of course there was a reporter from the New York Times who happened to be sitting at the next table, and as far as that reporter was concerned, the two men did not have an invisibility cloak around them. That's right. They definitely did not. So this reporter actually posted a photo on Twitter of the two attorneys talking, along with the caption, here's a photo of Ty Cobb and John Dowd, casually and loudly, discussing details of Russian investigation at BLT State DC. Well, I said it next table.
私下里，就在他们自己之间。当然，当时《纽约时报》的一位记者恰好坐在隔壁桌，对这位记者来说，这两个人身上可没有隐形斗篷。没错。他们绝对没有。所以这位记者实际上在推特上发布了一张这两位律师交谈的照片，并配上了这样的说明：这是一张泰·科布和约翰·多德在华盛顿特区BLT餐厅随意且大声地讨论通俄调查细节的照片。嗯，我说了是在隔壁桌。
And so I proceeded to order a few more iced teas and listen in on this very revealing conversation. Well, why do you think this happens, Erica? And what do you think explains the fact that we have almost these dual and conflicting social illusions? On the one hand, we believe that people are judging us harshly and perhaps being overly observant of our flaws. And on the other, almost simultaneously, we believe that we have a cloak around us that other people cannot see through. Yeah, so I am very interested in the psychology of what makes us so oblivious to the fact that these guys could be sitting and talking about sensitive information, not realizing they're being observed and not to sound conspiratorial,
于是我接着又点了厚几杯冰茶，并偷听了这段非常启发性的对话。那么，埃丽卡，你认为为什么会发生这种事？你认为该如何解释我们几乎同时拥有这两种双重且相互冲突的社会错觉？一方面，我们相信别人对我们严厉评判，甚至可能过度关注我们的缺点。而另一方面，几乎在同时，我们又相信自己身上有一件别人无法看透的隐形斗篷。是的，我对其中的心理学非常感兴趣，究竟是什么让我们对这些人可能坐在一起谈论敏感信息而毫无察觉、不知道自己正在被观察这件事如此浑然不觉，而且听起来并不是阴谋论，
not like you're watched all the time, but I think the point is, we can get into a mode where we are the people watchers, right? We're observing other people, we're looking around. I mean, just think about how much you do this, pretty much anytime you're in a public place. And the reality is that all the times that we're doing this, other people are also doing
就好像你不是每时每刻都被监视着，但我的重点是，我们可能会进入一种模式，即我们自己就是观察他人的人，对吧？我们在观察别人，四处张望。我的意思是，想想你在公共场所时，有多少次是这样的。而现实是，在我们这样做的所有时间里，其他人也同样在对我们
it toward us. They're watching us. And this is something that happened to me early on as I was starting to think about the invisibility collusion, but just sitting in a cafe and I'll be working and then periodically I'll look up all kind of gaze around the room. And everyone I see seems to be diligently also working like they're focused on their laptop or they're talking to someone else. But then what I know now based on my research is that as soon as I turn my attention back
这样做。他们在观察我们。这是我在开始思考隐形共谋时很早就遇到的一件事，当时我就坐在咖啡馆里工作，然后我会定期抬头环顾四周。我看到的每个人似乎也都在专职工作，就像他们专注于自己的笔记本电脑或在和别人聊天一样。但根据我现在的研究，我知道的是，一旦我把注意力转回到
to my computer, they're doing the same thing toward me, right? They're glancing at me. And so now I can't unknow that. This is something that I'm now much, much more aware of. Yeah. Do I remember correctly that you runs around an experiment where you had people come and sit in a waiting room, but the waiting room in fact was not a waiting room. It was actually the scene of the study that you were running and you were trying to measure the same exact phenomenon that we've been talking about. Right. And what's nice is there were two people there and we knew what they were doing while they were in each other's vicinity. And what we find is that people felt like they were
电脑上，他们也会对我做同样的事情，对吧？他们会瞥我一眼。所以现在我无法抹去这个认知。我现在对这一点有了更深、更深刻的意识。是的。我没记错的话，你做过这样一个实验：你让人们来等候室坐着，但这个等候室实际上并不是等候室，而是你正在进行的实验现场，你试图衡量我们刚才一直在谈论的那个确切现象。对的。好玩的是，那里有两个人，我们知道他们在彼此附近时都在做什么。我们发现，人们觉得自己是
the ones watching the other person. They didn't feel like the other person was watching them. And it's actually just really hard to catch people watching you, which is part of the reason we have this, we see this effect. So vision scientists call this gazed deflection. When we're looking at someone and watching them, we usually try to disguise it. But that means that the people who are looking at you are also trying to hide that fact. So it's very hard for us to gather evidence
那个观察别人的人。他们不觉得别人在观察他们。而且，要抓到别人在看你其实很难，这也是我们看到这种效应的部分原因。所以视觉科学家称之为“视线偏转”。当我们看着某人并观察他们时，我们通常会试图伪装。但这也意味着那些看着你的人也在试图掩盖这个事实。所以我们很难搜集到
that we're being watched. But when, as soon as we're not watching them, they're watching us. Yeah. So it seems to me that you're telling me that in different ways, we can both overestimate and underestimate the ways in which people notice us. Is there a tension between those two positions? I mean, how can those two illusions be happening simultaneously? Yeah, I mean, it's a good question. I think we can get into thinking that we are the ones kind of observing other people. And this is especially when we're not interacting with them directly. In that case, we often feel like we're the ones watching other people. But then when we're interacting with people, we're talking to them,
我们正在被观察的证据。但是，一旦我们不看他们，他们就会看我们。是的。在我看来，你的意思是，在不同的方式下，我们既会高估也会低估人们注意到我们的方式。这两种立场之间是否存在某种张力？我的意思是，这两种错觉怎么可能同时发生？是的，这是一个好问题。我想我们会陷入这样一种思维，即我们是那种会观察别人的人。尤其是在我们不与他们直接互动的时候。在这种情况下，我们经常觉得自己是观察他人的人。但当我们与人互动、和他们交谈时，
our critical voice turns on and we get more self-conscious, I think, and more concerned about the way that we're coming off to other people. And this can happen also, you know, kind of going back to the public Eskibar shirt, if people are wearing something that they are self-conscious about or feel weird about, that will also cause them to think someone is paying more attention to it. So we've talked a lot about our social interactions, but sometimes these social interactions are also being played out in memory. So we think back to conversations, you know, what we said, what someone else said. And one of the illusions that you've studied is that, you know, we think a lot about other people a lot and what they said, we replay conversations in our minds, but we don't
我们的批判性声音就会开启，我想我们会变得更加自我意识，更加担心我们给别人留下的印象。这种情况也会发生，你知道的，回到公共场合穿的衣服，如果人们穿着让他们感到不自在或奇怪的衣服，这也会导致他们认为有人对它给予了更多关注。所以我们讨论了很多关于我们的社会互动，但有时这些社会互动也会在记忆中重演。所以我们会回想谈话，你知道的，我们说了什么，别人说了什么。你研究过的其中一种错觉是，你知道的，我们会花很多时间去想别人以及他们说过的话，我们在脑海中重播谈话，但我们并不
assume that other people are doing the same thing. So exactly the same way that we believe that we're observant of other people, but other people are not observing us. We also think about other people a lot more than we realize that they are thinking of us. Can you talk about that phenomenon? Right. So, you know, we spend a lot of time in conversations in daily life, and we also spend a lot of time thinking about our conversations after they've taken place. So we think about the advice someone gave us, or maybe a funny story they told us, and we replay those moments. We remember them, we relive them. I think it's really clear to us when we're thinking about other people after we've interacted. But what we find is that people systematically underestimate how much they remain on the other people's mind after their conversation.
假设别人也在做同样的事情。所以，就像我们相信自己善于观察别人，而别人没有观察我们一样，我们想到的别人，也远比我们意识到他们想我们的要多。你能谈谈那种现象吗？好的。所以，你知道的，我们在日常生活的谈话中花了很多时间，我们也会花很多时间在谈话结束后去思考这些对话。所以我们会去想别人给我们的建议，或者他们告诉我们的一个有趣的故事，我们会重播那些时刻。我们记住它们，我们重温它们。我想在我们互动后回想其他人时，这对我们来说真的很清楚。但我们发现的是，人们系统性地低估了自己在对话结束后在别人心目中留存的程度。
Because they don't tell us, right? Just like we don't tell them, right? And this sort of just perpetuates this illusion. But I think we've looked at this to see kind of what some implications are in some specific context. So in one line of work, we looked at arguments. So arguments between friends or significant others. And we asked people how much they thought about the argument since it happened and how much they had replayed parts of in their mind. And also how much they thought about the argument since it happened and how much they had replayed parts of their mind.
因为他们没有告诉我们，对吧？就像我们没有告诉他们一样，对吧？而这恰恰延续了这种错觉。但我认为我们研究过这个问题，以了解其在某些特定背景下的一些影响。其中一个方向是争论。也就是朋友或重要伴侣之间的争论。我们询问人们，自从争论发生以来，他们想了多少，以及在脑海中重播了多少部分。还有，自从争论发生以来，他们想了多少，以及在脑海中重播了多少部分。
And also how much they thought their counterpart had. And again, we found people believe they were the ones thinking about the argument more. And if you're the one, you know, thinking about the argument, ruminating on it, concerned about it, but you think your partner is doing that much less, you know, that is going to make you feel a certain way, probably not a great way. And it affects your beliefs about how likely it is that your partner wants to reconcile or make up with you. You know, Erica, I spoke recently with the psychologist Emily Pronen, and one of the things she studies
以及他们认为对方想了多少。同样，我们发现人们相信自己才是更多思考这场争论的人。如果你是那个想着这场争论、反复琢磨、为此担忧的人，但你认为你的伴侣想得要少得多，你知道，这会让你产生某种感觉，可能不是什么好感觉。而且这会影响你的信念，即你的伴侣想要与你和解或重修旧好的可能性有多大。你知道，埃丽卡，我最近和心理学家埃米莉·普罗嫩（Emily Pronen）交谈过，她研究的其中一件事
is how when we think about our own minds, we have access to all this information. We're aware of our thoughts, our feelings, our hopes, our intentions. But then when we talk to others, we have a much more limited understanding of what's going on inside their heads. And that's because, of course, we're not inside their minds. How does this basic gap in perception shape the social illusions that you study? Yeah, I think it's a huge part of it. What we call the availability or accessibility of thoughts, right?
就是当我们审视自己的内心时，我们能够获取所有这些信息。我们意识到自己的想法、感受、希望和意图。但当我们与他人交谈时，对于他们脑海中正在发生的事情，我们的理解要有限得多。当然，这是因为我们不在他们的脑海里。这种基本的感知差距是如何塑造你所研究的社会错觉的？是的，我认为这是其中很大一部分。我们称之为思想的可用性或可及性，对吧？
And our own thoughts are hugely available and accessible to us. They're very salient. They come to mind, but we don't really have access to the inner workings of other people's minds. And so this is a huge problem that contributes to these illusions. The research of Michael Thomas-Sello and his colleagues recreated your liking gap experiment with children between the ages of four and eleven. The researchers paired the kids up and asked them to build a tower together and then they asked each child how much do you like the other boy or girl? How much would you like to be their friend?
我们自己的想法对我们来说是高度可用和可及的。它们非常显眼。它们会浮现在脑海中，但我们真的无法进入别人内心的运作方式。所以这是一个巨大的问题，它促成了这些错觉。迈克尔·托马塞洛（Michael Tomasello）及其同事的研究用四到十一岁的儿童重现了你的好感鸿沟实验。研究人员将孩子们配对，让他们一起搭建一座塔，然后询问每个孩子：你有多喜欢另一个男孩或女孩？你有多想成为他们的朋友？
Do you remember this experiment Erica and what they found? Yeah, so in this study, yeah, they looked at kids age four through eleven and what they found? Yeah, so in this study, yeah, they looked at kids age four through 11, and what they found is actually that the legging gap does not exist in four-year-olds, and it emerges actually this kind of critical period around age five, which is when young children are becoming more concerned with their reputations and the impressions that they make on other people.
你还记得这个实验吗，埃丽卡？他们发现了什么？是的，在这项研究中，是的，他们观察了4到11岁的孩子，他们发现了什么？是的，在这项研究中，他们观察了4到11岁的孩子，他们发现实际上4岁的孩子并不存在好感鸿沟，而这种鸿沟实际上是在5岁左右这个关键时期出现的，当时幼儿开始更加关注自己的声誉以及他们给别人留下的印象。
And then what's interesting is it also increases all the way to age 11, which is the upper limit of the range that they were testing in this study. And so we don't actually have data on teens, but I think for teenagers, the liking gap is probably massive. And I'd be really interested in kind of seeing what happens across adulthood, you know, as people get older. So it seems as if self-consciousness in some ways is sort of a crucial part of the liking gap in some of these social illusions.
有趣的是，这种鸿沟一直增长到11岁，这也是他们在这项研究中测试的年龄范围的上限。所以我们其实没有青少年的数据，但我认为对于青少年来说，好感鸿沟可能是巨大的。而且我真的很想看看成年期会发生什么，你知道的，随着人们年龄的增长。所以看起来，在某些方面，自我意识似乎是好感鸿沟和其中一些社会错觉的关键部分。
You know, very young children don't really care so much about what other people think of them. And so you could see why maybe they have fewer of these illusions, but if someone who is 16, 17, and high school teenager is thinking about this a lot because their social interactions really matter and how well they fit into the group really, really matter. And you can see perhaps as we go get older, perhaps it starts to fade away again and we become more self-confident and perhaps less self-conscious. I mean is that sort of the life cycle that you're seeing instead of the evolution of some of these social illusions? That's my hypothesis. I don't have the data yet to speak to this, but that is what
你知道的，非常小的孩子其实并不太在意别人怎么看他们。所以你可以明白为什么他们可能拥有较少这些错觉，但如果是一个16岁、17岁的高中青少年，他们会对此考虑很多，因为他们的社交互动真的很重要，他们融入集体的程度真的很重要。你可以看到，随着我们年龄增长，也许这种感觉又开始消退，我们变得更加自信，也许自我意识不那么强了。我的意思是，这就是你所看到的生命周期，而不是其中一些社会错觉的演变吗？这是我的假设。我还没有数据来支持这一点，但这就是
I would predict. We are collecting some data right now from people who are having conversations across generations. So we're collecting data from 30-somethings and 70-somethings. And we're having the 30-ish year olds talk to each other and the 70-ish year olds talk to each other. And then also these cross-generational conversations between them. And so I think what's interesting there is we can see if there are age effects such that younger people are showing a bigger, like,
我会预测的。我们现在正在收集一些数据，对象是跨代进行对话的人。所以我们正在收集30多岁和70多岁人群的数据。我们让30岁左右的人互相交谈，70岁左右的人互相交谈。还有他们之间的跨代对话。我认为有趣的是，我们可以看到是否存在年龄效应，比如年轻人表现出更大的好感鸿沟，
an older people, does it occur also controlling for who they're talking to, right? If they're talking to someone within their own age group or they're talking to someone of a different age group, whether that affects the, like, an gap as well. Do you think there are personality characteristics that make some of these social illusions either more likely or less likely? Yeah, so we have found that people who are more shy
而老年人呢？这是否也与他们交谈的对象有关，对吧？无论是与自己年龄段的人交谈，还是与不同年龄段的人交谈，这是否也会影响好感鸿沟。你认为是否存在某些人格特征，会使这些社会错觉更容易或更不容易发生？是的，我们发现比较害羞的人
exhibit a larger liking gap and I would expect that social anxiety would as well. We haven't measured a lot of personality variables. We've only tested a few kind of in the early days, but I would be interested in doing that in a larger sample to see what kinds of trends that we could find. And in the other direction, I might imagine that some personality trait like narcissism, for example, might cause people to have the opposite conclusion. They actually believe that they are the center of everyone else's world when, in fact, they're not. Right. That would be interesting to look at as well. Do you think there's a functional reason why our brains produce some of the social illusions, Erica?
会表现出更大的好感鸿沟，我预计社交焦虑症患者也是如此。我们没有测量很多人格变量。我们只在早期测试了几个，但我有兴趣在更大的样本中进行测试，看看能发现什么样的趋势。而在另一个方向上，我可能会想象某些人格特质，比如自恋，可能会导致人们得出相反的结论。他们实际上相信自己是其他人世界的中心，而事实上并非如此。对的。这也是一个值得关注的有趣方向。你认为你的大脑产生某些社会错觉，背后是否有某种功能上的原因，埃丽卡？
Why is it do you think that these exist in the mind? There definitely can be a function in terms of trying to improve for next time, especially with the laking gap. So if we're focused on our kind of self-critical thoughts, the times we fall short, the things we said that we wish we hadn't, thinking about those counterfactuals and how we could have done better
你认为这些存在于头脑中的原因是什么？就为下一次尝试改进而言，它绝对可以发挥某种功能，尤其是对于好感鸿沟。如果我们专注于那种自我批评的想法、我们表现不佳的时刻、我们说过希望没说过的话，去思考那些反事实以及我们本可以做得更好，
or we could improve for next time, might actually help us, it might help us make a better impression next time or become a more savvy social actor. But I think it also has some pitfalls. So I think we kind of need to find the right balance there. When we come back, how to become more aware of the social illusions that pervade our lives, and how to fight them?
或者我们本可以为下一次做得更好，这实际上可能会对我们有所帮助，它可能有助于我们在下一次留下更好的印象，或者成为一个更精明的社交参与者。但我认为它也有一些陷阱。所以我想我们需要在其中找到正确的平衡。当我们回来时，如何更加深入地认识到充斥我们生活的社会错觉，以及如何对抗它们？
You're listening to Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. We all wonder what other people think of us, and we all want to be liked. But we often walk away from conversations with friends and strangers, worried that maybe we talk too much, or didn't say enough, or said the wrong thing. Some of us spend sleepless nights worrying about how social interactions unfolded. Psychologist Erica Boothby studies how a perception of our social worlds are like looking into a fun-house mirror. She calls these distortions social illusions. Recognizing these illusions for what they are is an important first step to seeing things more clearly
你正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》（Hidden Brain），我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆（Shankar Vedantam）。我们都想知道别人怎么看我们，我们都希望被人喜欢。但我们常常在与朋友和陌生人的对话后离开，担心自己是不是说得太多，或者说得不够，或者说错了话。我们中的一些人会彻夜难眠，担心社交互动是如何展开的。心理学家埃丽卡·布斯比（Erica Boothby）研究了我们对社交世界的感知如何就像照着哈哈镜。她将这些扭曲称为社会错觉。认识到这些错觉的本质，是更清晰地看清事物的重要第一步。
Yeah, being aware of it I think can help and a lot of people have written me about the licking gap and said how much it resonates with them I've had clinical psychologists tell me that now they tell their patients about it and it's helped them feel better Just knowing that they're not alone that other people feel this way too and that does seem to help In addition to recognizing that these illusions exist, there are other techniques that can also help us to see our interactions with other people more clearly. Erika, when you first moved to Philadelphia to begin teaching at Wharton, you didn't know many people, so you made a coffee date with a friend of a friend. This was another young academic who was also new in town, and you were thrilled that you
是的，意识到这一点我认为会有所帮助，许多人曾写信给我谈到好感鸿沟，并说这让他们感同身受。曾有临床心理学家告诉我，他们现在会把这个概念告诉病人，这让他们感觉好受多了，仅仅知道自己并不孤单，别人也有这种感觉，这似乎确实有所帮助。除了认识到这些错觉的存在之外，还有其他技巧也能帮助我们更清晰地看待我们与他人的互动。埃丽卡，当你刚搬到费城开始在沃顿商学院教书时，你并不认识很多人，于是你和朋友的朋友约了喝咖啡。这是另一位同样刚来到镇上的年轻学者，你为自己
had made a new friend. But then you didn't hear back from her. How did your initial conversation go and what went through your mind when you didn't hear back? Yeah, so I really liked her. I could imagine becoming friends. Of course, I tried to contain my excitement and play it cool. And then a few days past, no word from her.
结识了新朋友而感到兴奋。但后来你没有收到她的回音。你们最初的对话进展如何？当你没有收到回复时，你的脑海里想些什么？是的，我真的很喜欢她。我可以想象成为朋友。当然，我试图克制自己的兴奋，表现得冷静。然后几天过去了，她没有任何消息。
I didn't get a text saying she enjoyed a conversation or anything following up. And so I just, I don't know, got a little worried. And I texted our mutual friend. I raved about what a great, interesting person she was. And I just said I wasn't sure, how much she liked me or if she'd actually be interested in meeting up again. I felt like I'd been kind of rambling a lot in the conversation.
我没有收到任何说她很享受这次对话或任何后续消息的短信。所以我只是，我不知道，有点担心。我给我们的共同朋友发了短信。我对她是一个多么棒、多么有趣的人赞不绝口，我只是说我不确定她有多喜欢我，或者她是否真的有兴趣再次见面。我觉得自己在对话中有点语无伦次。
I was nervous. The stakes felt kind of high. I didn't have any friends here. And so I wanted it to work out. But to my surprise, then my mutual friend wrote me back. And she said, that's so funny. You both texted me the same thing about each other. You should just text her. And so there was victim to my own effect.
我很紧张。赌注似乎有点高。我在这里没有朋友。所以我希望事情能顺利。但令我惊讶的是，我的共同朋友回信了。她说：“太搞笑了。你们俩发给我的关于彼此的短信一模一样。你应该直接发短信给她。”所以我成了自己效应的受害者。
I studied the Laking Gap. And so oftentimes I do try to check my self-critical voice and override it when I can. But for some reason in this moment, I really wasn't thinking like a scientist. I was just emotionally in the moment. But luckily, we in this case had our mutual friend to help set us straight.
我研究过好感鸿沟。所以通常情况下，我确实会试图克制自己批判的声音，并在可能的时候推翻它。但不知为何，在那一刻，我真的没有像个科学家那样思考。我只是沉浸在当下的情绪中。但幸运的是，在这个案子里，我们有共同的朋友来帮助我们拨乱反正。
Otherwise I'm just not sure we would have ever seen each other again, even though we both wanted to. I love the story because it really shows how sometimes we need to turn to friends to family members, to therapists, to help us see reality more clearly. Exactly. I think it all really helps in these cases to get an outside perspective. And I think intuitively many of us understand that this is valuable. I think what I take away from your work really is that it's really important to do this systematically, not just at a point where you feel like something has gone wrong, but to systematically invite third parties in to basically
否则我不确定我们是否会再次见到彼此，尽管我们两个人都想。我喜欢这个故事，因为它真正展示了有时我们需要向朋友、向家庭成员、向治疗师求助，以帮助我们更清晰地看清现实。完全正确。我认为在这些情况下，获得外部视角真的很有帮助。而且我认为凭直觉，我们中的许多人都能理解这是很有价值的。我认为从你的工作中汲取到的教训是，系统地做到这一点真的很重要，不仅仅是在你觉得事情出了问题的时候，而是要系统地邀请第三方介入，基本上是
say, what do you think is going on? What do you see happening here? Because it's possible that they will see things differently than you do. Yeah, I think that's exactly right. There's a second powerful idea in addressing these social illusions. I want to play you a clip from the TV show Ted Lasso, Erica. A woman is worried that a guy she's dating isn't as interested in her as she is in him. She thinks he might be seeing other people and she confronts him. So the other day when he said you were too busy to take me back. Yeah because I was busy. But you never told me what you were too busy with. Yeah because it was private. Are you dating other people? It's okay if you are. It's just that I want to know so that I don't know it's stupid. With yoga, okay? I do yoga with a group of women in their 60s.
说：“你觉得现在是什么情况？你看到这里发生了什么？”因为他们看到的可能与你不同。是的，我认为完全正确。在应对这些社会错觉时，还有一个强有力的第二个观点。埃丽卡，我想给你放一段电视剧《足球教练》（Ted Lasso）的片段。一个女人担心她约会的男人对她不像她对他那么感兴趣。她认为他可能在和别人约会，于是去质问他。所以那天他说你太忙了，没法送我回去。对，因为我很忙。但你从来没告诉我你忙什么。对，因为这是私事。你在和别人约会吗？如果是的话也没关系。我只是想知道，这样我就不会……哦，我知道了，很蠢。瑜伽，好吗？我和一群60多岁的女人一起练瑜伽。
They have no idea who I am. It's twice a week and it's really good for my call. You're never going to take it out. Erica, can you talk about the idea that sometimes a really effective way to find out what's happening in the minds of other people is to simply ask them? Yeah, I think this is a great example.
她们根本不知道我是谁。一周两次，对我的核心很有帮助。你永远不会把它拿出来的。埃丽卡，你能谈谈这样一种观点吗：有时弄清别人心里在想什么的一个非常有效的方法，就是直接去问他们？是的，这是一个很好的例子。
And it just shows kind of what we're talking about in terms of impression management, right? He doesn't want to share where he really was while he didn't text back because that is embarrassing for him. But on the other flip side, for her, she really needed to know. And so, yeah, I think this is a great example of how effective it can be to sometimes just ask, but there's reasons that we don't. And sometimes it's well-founded, right?
它恰恰展示了我们在印象管理方面所谈论的内容，对吧？他不想分享他没回短信时究竟去了哪里，因为那对她来说很尴尬。但在另一面，对她而言，她真的需要知道。所以，是的，我认为这是一个很好的例子，说明有时直接去问会有多有效，但我们不这么做是有原因的。有时这是有道理的，对吧？
On the one hand, we don't want to pry or be pushy. And we think that, you know, if someone didn't tell us something, there's reason for it. And we should kind of let them have that space. And on the other hand, as we don't ask people things directly, because we're afraid of what the answer might be. I want to talk about a third way to dismantle some of these illusions. Can you talk about the importance of trying to pay less attention to ourselves, you know, our own fears, our anxieties, our needs, and more attention to the other person, what they actually are saying and doing? How can that potentially play a role in dismantling some of these illusions?
一方面，我们不想窥探或显得咄咄逼人。我们认为，如果有人没有告诉我们某些事情，那是有原因的。我们应该给他们那种空间。另一方面，我们之所以不直接问别人事情，是因为我们害怕答案会是什么。我想谈谈打破其中一些错觉的第三种方法。你能谈谈试着少关注我们自己——你知道的，我们自己的恐惧、焦虑、需求，而多关注对方以及他们实际在说和做的事情，这种重要性吗？这在打破其中一些错觉方面如何潜在地发挥作用？
The research on social anxiety shows that if you go into a conversation with the goal of learning as much about your partner as possible, that that shifts your attention from being focused on your own thoughts and what you might be doing wrong, toward being focused on your conversation partner. And so I try doing this myself, and a lot of the thoughts that normally fuel the liking gap, are concerns about what people think of us,
关于社交焦虑的研究表明，如果你带着尽可能多地了解你的伴侣的目标去进行对话，这就会把你的注意力从关注你自己的想法以及你可能做错的事情，转移到关注你的对话伙伴身上。所以我自己也尝试过这样做，通常会助长好感鸿沟的许多想法，比如担心别人怎么看我们，
just aren't there when I'm more focused on the other person. So in conversations you're actually asking yourself, stay focused on the other person, stay focused on what's happening in their mind, let me try and understand them a little better. Yeah, I think even thinking about it not as try to stay focused on them, but if you actually think about it as trying to be curious about them and interested in them, that is actually
当我更多地关注对方时，这些想法就根本不存在了。所以在对话中，你实际上是在问自己：保持关注对方，保持关注他们脑海中发生的事情，让我试着更好地理解他们。是的，我想甚至不要把它想成“试着保持关注他们”，如果你把它想成对他们充满好奇并对他们感兴趣，那实际上
a better mental strategy. And it just gives you a different mindset altogether in the conversation. If you can kind of maintain your curiosity, ask them questions about themselves, ask them follow questions, like that's really where you want to be, and that will help you get more immersed in the conversation and less focused on yourself. I remember reading a research study maybe about a year or so ago, which talked about sort of how much people underestimate the power of asking questions and conversations,
是一个更好的心理策略。这会在对话中给你带来完全不同的心态。如果你能保持某种好奇心，向他们询问关于他们自己的问题，问他们后续的问题，这才是你真正想要达到的状态，这会帮助你更多地沉浸在对话中，而较少关注自己。我记得大约一年前左右读过一项研究，它谈到人们如何在对话中大大低估了提问的力量，
and how much they believe that a conversation is about making statements and offering their opinions, and how much more they're in fact liked when, in fact, they ask questions of the other person, which speaks exactly to what you're just saying, Erika. Exactly, I mean, it's a win-win because on the one hand, you're getting outside of your own head and your own self-critical thoughts,
以及他们多么坚信对话就是发表声明和表达意见，而事实上，当他们向对方提问时，他们会更讨人喜欢，这完全印证了你刚才所说的话，埃丽卡。完全正确，我的意思是，这是一场双赢，因为一方面，你走出了自己的脑海和自我批评的想法，
but also focusing on them, asking them questions, learning about them, makes them like you more. I wanna talk about one other idea, Erika, and this is not so much about removing the social illusions as much as it's about removing the social illusions as much as it's about preventing the social illusions from harming our relationships. You grew up near the ocean in Santa Cruz, California, and recently you've gone back to surf there. Can you tell me the story of the King of 38th Street? And what the story taught you about the power of compliments. Yeah, so I got really addicted to surfing a couple of years ago,
但同时关注他们、问他们问题、了解他们，也会让他们更喜欢你。埃丽卡，我想谈另一个想法，这与其说消除社会错觉，不如说它是为了防止社会错觉伤害我们的关系。你在加利福尼亚州圣克鲁斯的海洋附近长大，最近你又回去那里冲浪了。你能给我讲讲38街之王的故事吗？这个故事教会了你关于赞美力量的什么。是的，几年前我对冲浪上了瘾，
and I go to this spot at 38th, it's just a great beginner wave, and I spent a lot of time there, especially early on just trying to figure out how to ride waves, how to pop up, which is just getting from laying down on the board just standing up. And there was this guy, he's an amazing surfer, he's always out there,
我经常去38街这个地方，那是一个非常棒的初学者海浪点，我在那里花了很多时间，尤其是在早期，只是试图弄清楚如何冲浪、如何起乘，也就是从趴在板上到站起来。那里有一个家伙，他是个出色的冲浪者，他总是在那里，
and he was always in exactly the right spot, catching all the best waves. And my friends and I privately call him the king of 38th. And he has no idea about that, of course. But I always keep an eye on him when I'm out there because he's so good, he's so fun to watch, and I can really learn a lot from him. And so one morning I was out in the water,
他总是处在绝对正确的位置，抓到所有最好的海浪。我和我的朋友私下里叫他38街之王。当然，他对此一无我在。但我每次去那里都会盯着他，因为他太棒了，看他冲浪很有趣，我真的能从他身上学到很多东西。所以一天早上我在水里，
it was me, the king, and just a handful of other people, and I was having one of the best days I'd ever had. Catching just about every way I paddled for getting these really long rides, and all of a sudden, I saw the king of 38 himself paddling up to me, and I thought, oh no, for sure he's gonna tell me that I had done something wrong. So the cardinal sin in surfing is dropping in on someone,
当时只有我、国王和另外寥寥几个人，我度过了我有生以来最好的一天。几乎抓住了我划水追的每一道浪，并且滑行了很长一段距离，突然之间，我看到38街之王本人朝我划过来，我想，哦不，他肯定是要告诉我我做错了什么。所以冲浪的最大禁忌就是抢浪，
which just means paddling into a wave when someone else is already on it. And I thought for sure, I did something really dumb. I hadn't noticed and he was about to lecture me. But instead, he actually smiled at me, told me that my positioning was perfect and he noticed I just had a really nice natural style. And I was totally floored. I mean, this made my week absolutely because the king himself had
意思就是当别人已经在浪上时还划水追进去。我心想，我肯定做了什么非常蠢的事。我没有注意到，他正要训斥我。但相反，他实际上对我说，微笑了，告诉我我的站位非常完美，并且他注意到我有一种非常棒的自然风格。我完全惊呆了。我的意思是，这绝对让我这一周都开心极了，因为国王本人竟然
a notice me, b, he's seen that I was having a great day out there, and c, he bothered to come over and tell me about it. I mean, it was an amazing feeling. And there's a million times I've noticed people doing things that I really liked, but I usually kept those thoughts to myself. But after I got this compliment from the King of 38th, and knowing what I do now about compliments from my own research, I really try to make it a point to give people more compliments on the water instead of just keeping those thoughts to myself and not telling anyone. And I've noticed that that makes a huge difference.
a注意到我了，b，他看到我在水里度过了美好的一天，c，他特意过来告诉我这件事。我的意思是，那是一种奇妙的感觉。有无数次我注意到别人做了一些我真的很喜欢的事，但我通常把这些想法留给自己。但在我得到了38街之王的赞美之后，结合我从自己的研究中对赞美的了解，我真的努力在水里给人们更多的赞美，而不是把这些想法留给自己、不告诉任何人。我注意到这带来了巨大的改变。
I mean, people are always surprised when I compliment them when we're surfing because these compliments are kind of rare. Even though we're all sitting there thinking, plenty of nice things about each other, no one actually says what they're thinking. I'm wondering if one of the advantages of offering compliments is, in fact, people are often worried that other people don't like them. In fact, their self-concept is that other people don't like me as much as I like them.
我的意思是，当我们冲浪时，当我赞美别人时，他们总是感到惊讶，因为这种赞美有点罕见。尽管我们都坐在那里，心里对彼此有着各种美好的想法，但没有人真正说出自己的想法。我想知道，提供赞美的优势之一是否在于，人们经常担心别人不喜欢他们。事实上，他们的自我概念是别人不像他们喜欢别人那样喜欢自己。
And when people give us compliments in some ways, they are helping us to dismantle the liking gap. So we see that someone actually does actually like us, is coming up to say something nice to us. It helps to compensate for this bias that we're carrying around inside our own heads. I definitely think that's true. I also think that's why it's so surprising to us, it helps to compensate for this bias that we're carrying around inside our own heads. I definitely think that's true. And I also think that's why it's so surprising to us when we receive these compliments because we don't expect it, right? We kind of expect the worst from people in a sense. We don't realize how charitable they are socially or how positively they already think about
当人们在某种程度上给我们赞美时，他们正在帮助我们打破好感鸿沟。所以我们看到某人实际上确实喜欢我们，并走过来对我们说一些好话。这有助于弥补我们脑海中携带的这种偏见。我绝对觉得这是真的。我也认为这就是为什么当我们收到这些赞美时会感到如此惊讶，因为我们没有预料到，对吧？从某种意义上说，我们有点对人们抱有最坏的预期。我们没有意识到他们在社交上是多么慷慨，或者他们对我们的看法已经有多么积极。
us. So when they do give us these compliments, it's kind of a window into what they're actually thinking. Erica Boothby is a psychologist at the University of Pennsylvania's Wharton School. Erica, thank you for joining me today on Hidden Brain. Thank you so much for having me. Hidden Brain is produced by Hidden Brain Media. Our audio production team includes Bridget McCarthy, Annie Murphy Paul, Laura Quarelle, Kristen Wong, Autumn Barnes, Ryan Katz, and Andrew Chadwick. Tara Boyle is our executive producer. I'm Hidden Brain's executive editor. Our unsung hero today is Hidden Brain supporter Jacques Cofflin.
所以当他们确实给我们这些赞美时，这就像是一扇了解他们真实想法的窗户。埃丽卡·布斯比是宾夕法尼亚大学沃顿商学院的心理学家。埃丽卡，谢谢你今天做客《隐藏的大脑》。非常感谢邀请我。本节目由“隐藏的大脑”传媒制作。我们的音频制作团队包括布里奇特·麦卡锡（Bridget McCarthy）、安妮·墨菲·保尔（Annie Murphy Paul）、劳拉·夸雷尔（Laura Quarelle）、克里斯汀·王（Kristen Wong）、奥特姆·巴恩斯（Autumn Barnes）、瑞安·卡茨（Ryan Katz）和安德鲁·查德威克（Andrew Chadwick）。塔拉·博伊尔（Tara Boyle）是我们的执行制片人。我是本节目的执行主编。我们今天的幕后英雄是节目支持者雅克·科夫林（Jacques Cofflin）。
Jacques says he listens to the show in his ear buds while doing yard work or woodworking, and that one of his favorite episodes is separating yourself from the pack, our conversation about group dynamics with researcher Mina Chicara. Thanks so much for your support, Jacques. We really appreciate it. If you'd like to join Jacques in supporting the show, there are a few ways you can do so. You can go to support.hiddenbrain.org to make a contribution.
雅克说他在做庭院活或木工活时会戴着耳机听这个节目，他最喜欢的剧集之一是《将自己与人群剥离》，这是我们与研究员米娜·齐卡拉（Mina Cikara）关于群体动力学的对话。非常感谢你的支持，雅克。我们真的非常感激。如果你也想像雅克一样支持本节目，有几种方法可以做到。你可以访问 support.hiddenbrain.org 进行捐款。
Or you can become a subscriber to Hiddenbrain+. That's our new podcast subscription, where we'll bring you interviews and stories you won't find anywhere else. Like our recent interview with physician and novelist Abraham Vergis, about the person who inspired him to become a writer. You can try Hidden Brain Plus for free in the Apple Podcasts tab or by going to Apple.co-hiddenbrain. I'm Shankar dantım.
或者你可以成为 Hidden Brain+ 的订阅者。这是我们的全新播客订阅服务，我们将为你带来在其他地方找不到的访谈和故事。比如我们最近对医生兼小说家亚伯拉罕·维尔吉塞（Abraham Verghese）的采访，关于启发他成为作家的那个人。你可以在 Apple Podcasts 标签页中免费试用 Hidden Brain Plus，或者访问 Apple.co-hiddenbrain。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。
Siyussun. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
再见。这个剧集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可留下评论。